hello reject nation it's Greg Alva here
with Morgan Han from how to's and Morgan
and Ashley mm-hmm
she's here with me today we've been
catching up she's a delightful woman a
woman lady you're a delightful man who I
want to put you in a dark place right
now the five most haunting selfie posts
ever made with eerie explanations you
need to hear from one of my favorite
sounds top five unknowns Morgan and I
once did a something Internet scary
related people loved it I'm pretty sure
it's from this channel too yeah sir keep
em go I think that's what it was yeah
that's what this is yeah we did this is
me listening well I can't wait for you
to see this hopefully it's fun scary and
exciting
[Music]
get ready Morgan number five in July of
the 17th waited Tyler had bludgeoned his
parents to death with a hammer simply
because he wanted to have a house party
which they stood Wow I mean after
cleaning up the couple's blood for three
hours he did inviting over 60 guests to
his home but little did his guests know
his parents dead bodies were stashed
away in an upstairs closet my climbing
partner Hadley was just 15 years old
with his parents began to see sudden and
extreme changes in his behavior
according to his aren't around age 15
began skipping school hanging out with
the wrong crowd and getting involved
with drunks do not cool at the time
Tyler had 30 17 his parents claimed that
they had tried everything to get him
back on the right path in therapy
antidepressants mental health
evaluations and a substance abuse
program though nothing ever changed
between Tyler came home drunk from a
party for this his parents took away his
phone and car until further notice Japan
according to Tyler's on he apparently
thought that this was far too much and
told his bond that he wanted to kill her
his onset that she didn't believe he
would ever actually go through with it
course she's not seems as though he was
extremely angry by the fact that he was
being punished combined with the fact
that he was blackout drunk
before the house party the Tyler wanted
to have his parents took him to a family
reunion located near a cabin in Georgia
members of his family said he looked
completely normal and seemed as though
he was doing great
making the impending death of his
parents seem much more bizarre on the
day of the murders
Tyler posted an invitation to Facebook
about the pilot was hosting claiming
that his parents had gone away to
Orlando Florida for the weekend
according to times are on his watering
the case awesome
and most of the people that he invited
to the party weren't even his friends
during the party
Tyler pulled his best friend Michael
Mendel aside it's assumed that he had
something important to tell the two left
the house and spoke on the front lawn
where Tyler informed him that he had
killed his parents according to Michael
he was a first in disbelief but Tyler
then told him Mike
look at the driveway all the cars are
there I killed my parents
after this Michael found blood by a
computer desk as well as blood outside
of Tyler's parents doorway though he
assumed that he was simply playing a
prank on to this Michael insisted that
he wanted to see their dead bodies in
order to believe it Tyler took into his
parents bedroom and insisted that
Michael check for himself telling him
that they were stored away in the club
Oh Michael open the door and sure enough
there they were after making this
discovery Michael stayed at the party
just a few more hours it was a few hours
he just discovered the two best friend
was a serial killer you certainly
wouldn't need the party right away oh
that's me I'll even took a photo with
Tyler stating that he knew this would be
the last time that he saw following this
just a few hours later Michael
fourth-graders Tyler was then taken into
custody and given two life sentences
without the possibility of goodbyes or
harsh max from Pennsylvania shot his
friend then took a photo with his
lifeless body
the death of his friend was definitely
quote messed up he continued it
sometimes sorry isn't enough for people
but that's all I have to give Martin was
then convicted of third-degree burn this
progressed he claims did the two a plate
with a handgun and neither of the media
was loaded he then pointed at his friend
and pulled the trigger he claims that he
took the photo to document what had
happened and in order to immediately
kill himself from the guilt stating that
he was one of his best friends according
to max turns hitting to be rappers at
the time of the incident
he says that the clip wasn't in the gun
a fact that hasn't been confirmed by
police and that he then called the
trigger and the gun went ah however
another team in the area claims that
Maxwell had actually bragged about the
killings well - were playing video games
together claiming Metapod got his first
body the friend says that he didn't
believe about first and I saw the photo
he had taken off his friend's body
according to Maxwell's defense attorney
the court was seeking to put Maxwell
away for 40 years though he argued that
if Maxwell hadn't taken that photo and
had instead simply focus you likely fees
no prison time whatsoever
regardless we expose two additional
arrests involving a violent crime as
well as the photo max was sentenced to
15 to 30 years in prison I want to see
the photo
oh come on show us the photos shocking
photos have recently been made public
showing a nurse who's believed to have
murdered dozens of patients Oh
showing your opposing with a dead woman
in Daniella Pacquiao was arrested in
October of 2014 after evidence was found
indicating issues involved in the deaths
of at least 38 patients coming behind to
is labeling the deaths of most of these
individuals as highly suspicious
in fact an autopsy on one of the
individuals a 78 year old woman she
would abnormally high levels of
potassium chloride in her system which
is an essential vitamin
though when taken in large doses
potassium chloride can stop your heart
rhythms and even death this is actually
the compound given to death row inmates
yeah in much higher dose
Wow she was forced into helping daniela
take the photos and express severe
discomfort and doing so according to
this worker and remains unnamed
danielle was known for getting will
accidents to patients strictly to make
it difficult for the nurses on the next
shift is prior knowledge about the
offences both she and in yellow have
been arrested and are awaiting trial for
the what an evil woman evil but the BTK
killer most well known for his bizarre
means i could all friends obsessed with
sexual fetish of wearing his feet
victims night if who were female and one
male his title of BTK originated from
messages he left on or near his victims
with ptk meeting beat torture kill ohh
dennis is known victims residing that's
what it means at the moment there's only
one known victim who actually escaped
being captured by a 63 year old woman by
the name of Anna Williams in 1979 Denis
claims to him waited outside of her
house for hours expecting her to arrive
home she never did he sped up she spent
the night out with friends this angered
that is deeply causing to leave her home
and never
then this was also too stocked and
number of women though there's new
evidence suggesting that he had any
intent to kill them of these women once
successfully filed a restraining order
while the others simply move the way 17
years
Sam's this is also well known for the
games he played with police taunting
them with letters and messages for over
thirty years in these messages he
included vague clues about himself as
well as occasionally including photos of
his victims claiming responsibility for
their death by 2004 it had been over 12
years since Dennis's last letter was
received by police the case of the BTK
killer had run cold
however seemingly out of nowhere letters
began coming in technology which helped
determine their origin led to the arrest
of Dennis to sacred fires following this
he was given 10 life sentences in prison
desperately 72 years old and resides in
the El Dorado Correctional Facility in
2014 Angela Wrightson was a 40 year old
alcoholic who's known for having little
if any friends she often invited
strangers or passers-by into her home so
a conversation and a drink in fact it
was this exact action that ultimately
led to her death and until their often
sit on the doorstep of her heart pool
hole according to court records Angela
had a habit of allowing underage
children to drink or smoke at her
presence in December 2014 two girls aged
13 and 14 angel
asking that she buy them alcohol Angela
considered the girl's friends and
immediately individual injuries
including being beaten stabbed then
tortured with a wooden stick during
these attacks and following these
attacks the girls posted photos of
themselves to snapchat a decision in
which ultimately led to their arrest
after the two girls were arrested they
were both determined to be severely
mentally ill and being hurt and they
body engine last times
try with the older girl even being her
head repeatedly into a Great Wall the
girls have yet to be sentenced the judge
has stated that the minimum amount of
time shall receive is twelve years yes
so they're gonna say she was a killer
Thanks top five unknowns hours how's a
great list I'm so walk home you don't
have to walk home you gotta drive it to
your garage in your apartment just know
this just not this no okay Morgan is
that I really believe in law of
attraction so if you are holding on to
these thoughts you are more likely to
attracting murder to you yeah I mean
that's kind of true but like I thought
like you can't positively stink someone
dead
like it feels like someone cuts you off
traffic yes you can but like yeah not in
the way that you were saying we'll see
about that
I'll make sure of it let's talk about a
couple of these this first of all I
thought that guy was one of the worst
ones of these five it's kind of hard for
ranking he should have been number one
he's the worst
was the first guy who killed his own
parents they're gonna throw a
housewarming party he blood you to them
to death with a hammer oh my goodness my
gosh you know I have a new roommate
you guys might know him John he's been
on this channel a couple of times so
many times I want to invite people over
and I have a hammer just in case he
doesn't let me have someone over like he
wanted to be in this video today with us
there's a reason he's in the bedroom we
haven't seen him all night
well did you say goodbye to him okay
has he ever prevented you from having
people over before yes and it has led
many times I've told him like if you
keep doing this John I might get out of
hand I might
well on a serious note this guy
shouldn't have done it he kind of
overreacted a little bit just have a
housewarming party I cannot believe he
did that one I can't believe he hid them
upstairs in the closet because there was
no time or whatever I can't believe he
told Tyler I think that was yeah Tyler
guy was like photo with you because this
will be the last time I see that was a
little weird though for real what would
you done would you left right away cuz
then he would have cereal killed you I
would have called the cops right away
right away right away I don't know who
called I would least text someone you
wouldn't wait in a few hours like I
would have I would have gone to the
bathroom would have called the police
and yeah I probably would have called
the police right away
I would've played it off smart you're
funny guy dude hey man I'm gonna go take
a [ __ ] really quick damn that way if I'm
in there for a long time on hold because
you know how 9-1-1 can be can I put you
on hold for 911 yeah they do every time
I go I call I call like at least once a
month so gret I know it's you Greg hold
on you call every month all the
important to you when I feel comfortable
making jokes we know I know death we've
been in the darkness then why why why
you why watch your video around so heavy
yeah there's great stuff and then
there's some shitty you should include
that in your self help book that you're
told you are right that's me a chapter
life is shitty my that should be the
last chapter she's like you should be
like yes I love falling in love I didn't
really
there was so much [ __ ] that came with it
I'm like yes yes yes therapist whose
name will not be disclosed in this video
they can't talk about you but you can
say their name yeah because they don't
want everyone going yeah I don't want
everybody to go to here it takes away
from me yeah the second story though of
this guy who shot his friend I wanted to
see that picture and I was really took a
photo with the dead body
this cuz me thinking about a very recent
incident the other day a friend from
Texas was visiting and he showed us that
because he was from the military and he
has a gun and I've never been gun
shooting before so he took John and I to
his car and he gave me his gun and he
like emptied the clip and he checked the
chamber first to make sure there was no
bullets in it and he was showing me how
to aim and then John was there and he
was like you know dodging and stuff I'm
like it's empty so I'm like John quit
being a [ __ ] but then watching this I'm
like you gonna kill me you don't know
that makes me nervous to like do an
action movie there's like ones like two
and a clip and one in the chamber their
face of clave you have to enter the
chamber because the chamber is it yes
you always got to make sure it's empty
and we did so when John was like dodging
I was like man what a [ __ ] but this
this shows John was smart there was a
bullet in there and he shot John I would
have to get a new roommate to help out
with the pill and then I would grieve
afterwards focus on priorities money
money
well the friendships over at that point
I take responsibility it's not a move
this third story though this one is this
is an evil woman right here I mean the
guy she could have killed I know that's
that is a scary part it's like who was
this woman and what was her motivation
for all these things it was a serial
killer and she was like he has a
hospital this woman though I'm thinking
that she or like nursing school with the
intention of killing people like this is
the perfect cover-up I can go to nursing
school but then she was also like Dexter
yeah yeah like we're training her self
so that way she could get away with
murder so I'm thinking like did she kill
people before
it was a nurse or did she get driven to
a point to kill people when she was
another do you think serial killers grow
up thinking they're gonna be serial
killers so they just one day end up as a
serial killer a little bit sometimes a
little bit of both sometimes they kill
someone when they're younger and then
eventually when they get older and they
have more control over their life they
start abusing whatever control they have
to kill I've seen minehunters on Netflix
I'm not oh it's a really good show
speaking of mine hunter BTK killers in
that one yeah that's yeah that's how I
learned about him and he for yeah this
is real lady told me about him and she
actually has a strong fascination with
serial killers it was funny as all her
ex-boyfriends have all gone missing
about a year into them dating I don't
have a plan a burger job I just I'm
actually shot on a cover BTK killer yeah
he's only caught a few years ago I mean
this guy got away with murder for 17
years longer than that 30 years because
he he'd killed for 17 years and he
stopped for a long time and then he came
back again like he made a comeback what
I do though every episode of Bones I've
watched the successful serial killers
went away for a bit
and then they resurfaced yeah yeah
that's like it's like they it's kind of
like alcohol treatment you know like
when you relapse have you been sober for
so on and then you relapse me have this
incident this guy he had a family and
everything man crazy do you think you
would be a successful serial killer me
because you've seen like have you seen
enough like a TV show so I've watched
enough bones I really feel like I could
hide it violate and it would not be
found I really feel like I could I
really feel like I couldn't get caught
really I don't think I could kill
somebody yeah that's that that's that's
that's my fail my favorite I think if I
could be success I think if I was
willing maybe still one time
though I don't think it would be a good
like long-term yeah this is our cover
right here for our terminating video we
couldn't do it but we could well we we
could but I know I can do I don't think
I could take a life like a barely kill a
bug oh man but this one I mean at first
I was like grossed out with the old lady
because I thought I thought they were
gonna say she killed and then I found
out oh she's okay
they killed her they just really beat
the [ __ ] out of her that's what sounds
like because it's an old sweet old lady
who got little girls of charge
Wow I've said the horrible how can you
beat an old lady how can you beat an old
lady ah well that's different every
month my name on one phone calls are
about the attack your old man hey guys
you can subscribe to the real rejects
and click that notification bell please
follow Morgan Han on how to's with
Morgan and Ashley a great how to channel
and check out their Instagram if you
just want to see her pretty face how to
blondes make a right go check it out
right there and by the way you can
become a patron oject today it's awesome
over there we post daily exclusive
content and everything you guys you know
pledge helps out with the channel much
love reject nation don't kill